il aurait pu être face à face lors des
prochaines élections municipales
attrape les deux hommes feront
finalement front commun othman nasri
pourra compter sur une alliance avec
mustapha larbaoui l'ont annoncée
aujourd'hui est le conseiller municipal
d'opposition avaient appelé la semaine
dernière le pharmacien et ancien
président du club de football à le
rejoindre pour le scrutin mustapha
larbaoui qui avait pensé un temps être
candidat avant de renoncer
il rejoint donc othman nasri qui reste
candidat principal dans une liste
commune nommée engagement trappe
citoyens et les propos sont recueillis
par marylène yapi shiloh c'est la main
tendue que j'attendais je vous cache pas
que on est venu me voir parent par
ailleurs monsieur malandain par exemple
voilà mon choix s'est porté maintenant
sur la candidature de rothmans nasri et
avec mon groupe avec engagement trappe
nous travaillerons en ce sens et nous
apporterons les solutions nécessaires au
changement et à l'avenir de cette ville
est un rassemblement qui ne soit pas un
rassemblement partisan parce que
l'avenir de la ville aujourd'hui passent
pas par l'opposition entre la droite et
la gauche et passe par un projet et puis
passe par des compétences et la
compétence de mustapha larfaoui elle est
incontournable et donc c'est
naturellement que j'ai proposé qu'on
fasse équipe quand on forme un vrai duo
un vrai partenariat et les deux hommes
annonceront les grandes lignes de leur
programme
après les vacances de la toussaint a
noté 4 ap le maire divers gauche sortant
guy malandain a annoncé son souhait de
briguer un quatrième mandat en 2020 pas
de candidatures déclarées encore du côté
de l'adjoint ali rabais qui a lui
enregistré la semaine dernière le
soutien de benoît hamon